kate let's get them out
it's been a wonderful way to discover a
lot more of the humanity of who clint
barton is
he was wonderful in showing me the ropes
and collaborating with me in finding
this amazing dynamic between clint and
kate
you're a hawkeye
who the hell are you
kate bishop saw what clint barton could
do as hawkeye
that really inspired her to be like him
seeing the comic page come to life on
the screen is what has excited me for
the past 20 years
what is equally exciting is the
enthusiasm that the actors themselves
bring to evolving these characters my
relationship with haley is our little
heartbeat throughout our stories stop
making me like you i'm sorry i can't
deal with it it's amazing what happens
when you let actors like jeremy renner
really have the space to explore their
character and their backstory
first two weeks of shooting this i've
said more than i've said the entire mcu
universe
there's so much great source material
there's a lot more story to tell